Is it morally right to bring people into
existence without their consent and
knowing that they will inevitably
intrude suffering during their life?
Isn't it selfish?
Good question.
Tolstoy.
I asked that question.
So if you're interested in,
in an answer that question.
No.
One of the things I would recommend that
you read that book because that was kind
of history.
We looked at last thought.
Yeah.
He tells this story.
It's a story about this guy.
You told her he's being chased by people
who want to kill him.
So he jumps into this hole and he's
hanging on.
It's like an old whale.
It's hanging on for dear life to this
scratching and at the bottom of the hole
there's a crocodile and so he's hanging
on there.
I'm always.
How you gone?
He noticed this two phase.
There's some grapes on the vine and then
there's about two mice,
one's black and one's white and all of a
sudden they're on.
You either started buying into chewing
through it so he knows,
you know,
and Nick Yoder,
you could fall and get killed or he
could wait last.
So what do you guys eat?
The grapes,
you don't want to.
It's a Buddhist store that was story
because the white mouse is chaos or
order in the black house is chaos and
there's always things working at the
vitamin B.
There's no doubt about it.
You know you're screwed no matter what
you do,
which is the moral of that story and
tolstoy.
He looked at that story and said,
look,
the only logical conclusion that you can
draw from that is that life is so
terrible that it shouldn't exist.
And hey,
dusty asked the same question in
probably is chromosome.
You have this therapy.
It was just smart.
Good wrote being tough guy,
good intellect,
perceptive and yes,
this revenue down the Osha who's kind
of.
He's a soft guy in some ways.
He's not an intellect,
but he's really a good person now.
He was just kind of classically
religious sneezes.
He wants to be vitiated monastery again.
And I would just talk to the because he
can blow over with his intellect.
You know,
and I can tell us the story about the
Gospel asked you took from the
newspaper,
this family,
mother and father,
they were angry at their four year old
daughter and her house overnight and she
was screaming out there using and not
even basically says to know who's making
the case for the goodness of being on
the goodness of God even says bothered.
How can you bothered?
It's like this is the sort of thing that
happens in the world all the time,
and then you ask them what the Osha Law,
when you willing voluntary torture that
girl to get to ensure that things would
continue.
Alicia says,
well,
no,
I was doing and what I know you wouldn't
do it.
So it's like,
what's your conclusion about that being
shouldn't exist?
And then Girtha asks the same question.
He is a firehouse is character in that
they,
that the software works and metastases.
This is kind of the intellectual ankle
of Satan.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And he says the same thing.
He's talking about his motivation.
He says,
well,
what motivates the great adversary of
mankind?
Straightforward being so terrible that
it should be eradicated.
Okay,
fair enough.
Strong people try it.
It's not clear to me that that's where
we should go.
So because as far as I can tell,
when people work for the eradication of
being,
it makes everything that they're
complaining about way worse,
really fast.
And so then the other thing you might
ask yourself is,
do you think that's the motivation?
It's really so pure heart.
You know they're going to destroy
mankind to save and they're making a
judgment.
The judgment is being is so terrible
that it shouldn't exist.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
I get the rationale,
the Ivan's rationale.
It was never clicked more strongly than
in the brothers Karamazov.
It's a famous passage and writing.
So the question is with regards to
bringing children into the world,
mom,
it's a variation of the same question.
You know the question is what do you
have to conclude if you're not willing
to do it,
you're completely with bed is not with
the being is not just a particular.
Well that's a hell of a conclusion.
I would be very careful before I made it
because there are places it takes you
that's not good,
so and then you might also ask yourself,
are you so sure that you're asking that
question just because you're a good
person or you may be asking that
question because you don't want the
response to say,
of having a child in his finger and
said,
or maybe you're afraid that you won't
know how to fortify the child property,
so you're withdrawing the fair.
Fair enough.
Look what do you do with children
because you encouraged them and I mean
that literally.
It's like you have a little kid and you
say,
look,
you can take on the world and you don't
sugarcoat it just like it's not.
It's all fairy tales and roses.
It's not.
Neil is shield things enough so you
don't damage them.
It's a very tight balancing because you
don't want to know what to overwhelmed.
Someone hurt them while you're teaching
them.
You have to expose him gradually and
with intelligence and you do that by
having a relationship with the kid.
You don't want to shield them from
existence.
We want to show them just what it's like
and then you want to tell them it
doesn't matter,
man,
you're tough enough.
You can do it and you can do it right
and it's true.
They can and if you see four to five and
with that knowledge they are,
they're being is not characterized by
the kind of suffering that makes
existence intolerable and so the answer
is not to have children.
The answer is cooperative and encourage
them and that's tough because you don't.
You're kind of fragmented,
been broken,
and if you treat your child,
they might exceed me.
That's annoying.
So you may do everything you can to
bloody well made sure that your kid is
broken enough so there's no way they're
going to do any better than you,
and so I wouldn't recommend that,
but people do it all the time,
but that doesn't mean that existence
itself is insufficient.
It just means that you're not handling
the property and you're making it far
worse than it has to be.
In.
One of the things I asked myself a long
time ago,
first of all,
I know there's a distinction between
tragedy and that's an important
distinction.
Tragedy is when things happen that
aren't good,
someone gets cancer.
You know your child slips and breaks,
his or her labor.
Know your parents guide.
That's tragic.
Evil is when something tragic happens
because someone wanted it.
Tap.
Okay,
so we can distinguish between ell
students.
The first thing I would say is people
can have a tragedy like you can get
tough enough so you can have,
in fact,
I think you can get tough enough so that
you even get tougher if you're exposed
to trash.
That sort of his statement about,
you know,
whatever doesn't kill me,
makes me stronger.
Obviously it's an overstatement.
It's very hard for people to tolerate
evil level ones.
So like I've seen people,
for example,
is adolescent clients with posttraumatic
stress disorder.
Very often traumatized by malevolence,
not tragic.
They fall victim to someone who wants to
hurt and maybe it's even self that wants
to hurt them and that's revealed to
them,
you know,
but sometimes they come into their often
naive people to come into contact with
someone whose purpose is to hurt them
and that shadows so badly to kind of put
themselves back together.
Evils really devastated.
I think human beings can tolerate
tragedy and I also think that if people
oriented themselves towards the
improvement of being,
we could continually ameliorate tragic
and I do also believe that being is
striving to perfect itself.
Now that's obviously a metaphysical
statement,
but I don't really care if it's a
medical metaphysical statement.
I have my reasons for for bleeding and I
think that the purpose of human life is
to participate in that process and
because again,
the alternative is things are quite
lists and life is suffering and it
should be eradicated.
It's like that leads nowhere.
Good really leads nowhere.
Good,
so I can dispense with it.
It's better than where it takes you.
It's like a bad roadmap because most
profound ideas,
our roadmap,
they tell you how to get from one point
to another.
Do you want to get to the depths of
infertile chaos or do you want to move
towards something that approximates
paradise?
Well,
he better make sure you have the right
map and so and most belief systems,
our roadmaps,
they're descriptions of reality in our
description to objective reality there.
That isn't what they are,
so have kids to say,
it's one third of your life.
You will bloody won't regret it if you
don't do it.
You're not going to be forever or 30.
Some days you're going to be 50 or 55
and maybe it will be alone.
That's not so good and so you're a fool
if you don't have kids.
Now,
I mean,
I know people have their reasons and
some people have appropriate reasons and
all that,
but if it's somebody ideological hangup
that stopping you,
if you better dispense with that
instead,
instead of dispensing with the kids.